MECs 'it is the talk of the town in
Toronto laney Louie is a celebrated
royal watcher in Canada and she thinks
the future could well be bright for
Megan and Harry I think that this
decision wasn't taken lightly and if
they had to make the decision it must
have been that things were unworkable
the way they were before but I also am
really excited nothing's ever been done
like this before they're working out a
new role and they're imagining a new
position for themselves I as a watcher
as a citizen of the world I think that
this is really I don't know it could be
really fresh do you think they will be
embraced in Canada and be more at ease
in a way they couldn't be in America or
England
totally Canadians are a little bit more
discreet about it because we kind of
love when people love our country she's
my lawyer this is why Megan markle's
starred in the legal drama suits of your
most prominent properties she lived here
before moving to the UK and this bakery
is one of the places she shopped before
some say she revived the royal family
what is it now
[Music]
in terms of modernizing it you mean
I don't know if I can be modernized like
it's a pretty historical imperialist
institution mega Markel came here too
and there's hope she could still go
incognito
I guess depends with the life they want
to live I guess over here because
they're definitely some places you could
hide this is a city where the Sussex is
could chart a path to independence the
Dutch House of Sussex has been able to
return to Toronto relatively under the
radar since joining the royal family
quietly catching up with friends Canada
could now offer her and Prince Harry
more privacy and freedom it just depends
how much they want but the situation is
deeply complicated and no one knows
exactly where or how they will find
their place woody Lee lived Stein ease
Toronto Canada